Kyra Lhasa tea guys Jeremy's on Jeremy
Lin
jaelyn on my way to practice I only have
a few minutes crack are we talking about
practice I'm not nice i person oh thank
you
dude don't do it I like Iverson you know
what rewind in a race so um I told me
you guys have some video idea
do we ever first up you star as Jeremy
Lin Manuel Miranda in your own hit
musical slam Bolton all about the
history of basketball Jordan wrote the
whole thing himself
it just pour right out of me no Mac
alright uh I do number two you know that
Kyrie Irving video where he dresses up
like an old man and in place pick up
basketball with some kids at the park
yeah uncle drew except this is reverse
uncle drew this is baby true we put you
in a ball cap in a onesie drop you off
at Rucker Park now first you can't walk
and talk
well a baby just like a baby but then
you take it to the court in a diaper and
you dominate dominate
what's your catchphrase I want my bad I
love my Baba I'm not playing basketball
on a diaper let's do something more like
family friendly you know connect with
the fans like uh candid camera oh yeah
yeah yeah worse yes we love candid
camera love that camera you know what we
will talk to you next week next week
Weezy can you google candid camera
there is mr. fancy NBA star arriving in
a show for chariot I'm impressed man uh
it's a lift
it's a lift to viral video fame and
fortune let's get you miked up yeah okay
just so excited why velocity hitting
camera shoot take one hi ma'am
all right here we go first mark you like
basketball hey Soph can't use that now I
can do
Cara Meehan you're doing great but how
you doing terrific weird how many people
curse like that I know hey you guys nuts
bad oh yeah hey no did you just use me
as a human shield no I would never just
push me I'm a third party objectively
you you definitely used her as a human
shield
wait for me thanks a lot eat a dick man
Tony why does he have to eat it I don't
know ah look no one's having fun your
idea right I mean how could it go wrong
another kids crying what posture erase
that please go ahead here you go you G
is this look like a haunted house
take care look at him surly knock don't
worry about it man oh no I got a couple
takes left we're almost done let's reset
back to one whatever that means
guys want some free stuff hey what's up
I was great in all right I don't know if
this is a going as planned
oh it's great hey don't worry about it
it just means we love you in Brooklyn
yeah one more buddy pop big surprise
Brooklyn Oh
oh my god this is taking a turn yes take
a turn sir you okay yeah all right okay
it's fine it's fine it's been that a
baby aspirin and a minute I can't take
care of you know what we should yeah
let's call in the lift so Jimmy we're
done that's a wrap everybody
cover your face with this big round of
applause for our fake picked up great
job buddy
great job huh yeah you were great
he loves you I'm okay and you're okay we
can fix him post